[Música]
revista de prensa de hoy viernes 11 de
febrero ya está conmigo lista en el
estudio rosa pérez más de eeuu la
encargada de esta sección rosado
bienvenida feliz mañana vamos a abrir
esta revista de prensa con the economist
y su informe anual que estábamos
avanzando sobre el estado de la
democracia en todo el mundo que en
referencia al año 2021 rosa el año
pasado señala un nuevo mínimo para la
democracia buenos días efectivamente
este informe de the economist concluye
que menos del 50 por ciento de la
población mundial vive en una democracia
lo que supone el mayor retroceso
democrático de 2010 este año en plena
crisis económica global y este índice
para realizarlo de economista ya tiene
en cuenta distintos parámetros dentro de
cada país como el plural el pluralismo
la cultura política o las libertades
civiles y en este caso respecto al año
2021 se atribuye a esta caída
democrática en gran parte a las medidas
las restricciones impuestas para
controlar la pandemia y tal y como
señala la nación de argentina américa
latina sufrió la mayor caída del mundo
en él de la democracia según the
economist que señala que solo pues
uruguay y costa rica son democracias
plenas en la región y si tú lo sitúa a
cuba y a venezuela en la la cola es
regional de este ranking y si bien a
nivel mundial también señala que sólo 21
países del mundo tendrían también un
sistema democrático pleno pero hay que
destacar raúl que también hay críticas
cada año sobre pues la autoridad que
puede tener un medio de comunicación y
particularmente del coni mode economist
con su respectiva ideología para hacer
este tipo de clasificaciones rosa y
vamos ahora con un tema que también se
puede relacionar con el estado de la
democracia y la importancia de la
transparencia hablamos de la entrevista
realizada por el periodista del diario
punto es el es javier y oscar creydt
whitlock el periodista que está por las
mentiras de la guerra en afganistán que
hay sobre esto rosa este periodista en
la entrevista señala que eeuu sabía que
los talibanes tomarían el poder bien
este es un periodista del washington
post que en 2016 recibió de una fuente
que le comunicó que una agencia
gubernamental estaba entrevistándose con
distintos generales del ejército
estadounidense para saber lo que estaba
pasando sobre el terreno en afganistán
el 'washington post' solicitó a través
de la justicia basándose en la ley de
transparencia las transcripciones de
todas estas entrevistas y lo que
concluyeron no leyendo todas estas
declaraciones es que des de baix hasta
hasta by den pasando por obama y trump
todos los periodistas mintieron respecto
a la guerra de afganistán no que en el
mal en el mejor de los casos no sabían
lo que estaba sucediendo bien bien sobre
el terreno pero incluso el ex secretario
de defensa donald rumsfeld que falleció
recordemos este 2021 dijo no sé quiénes
son los malos en afganistán bien todas
estas informaciones estas revelaciones
sobre lo que se conocía de esa guerra y
se ocultó durante 20 años los encontrará
pues ya en un libro traducido en español
los papeles de afganistán
bueno rosa y continuamos en eeuu pero en
el capitolio porque becarios y
trabajadores de los eslabones más bajos
de la jerarquía se rebelan con el
estatus qué hay dentro de ese recinto y
como lo titula el 'new york post' vaivén
apoya a su intención de sindicarse una
medida que también apoya a nancy pelosi
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu pero la medida
para permitir esta sindicación de los
trabajadores del capitolio debería ser
aprobado tanto por la cámara de
representantes como por el senado y
porque se quieren sindicar los
trabajadores de los eslabones más bajos
del capitolio pues por protestar y
luchar por una mayor justicia de los
salarios luchar contra la explotación
laboral o contra la discriminación
racial no distintos medios y distintos
trabajadores señalan una falta de
diversidad como en la de christian
science monitor que dice quien elabora
las políticas públicas o el latín revés
que señala la importancia de una cuenta
de instagram que se llama your white
staff querido personal blanco que ha
servido como plataforma de denuncia de
distintas injusticias cambiamos ahora de
temeridad cuando la falta de agua tiene
el mismo efecto devastador que el estado
islámico rosa
exactamente este es un reportaje que se
centra en la sequía extrema que afecta
al país donde las precipitaciones han
disminuido
terriblemente y lo que afecta pues a la
agricultura ya la ganadería y donde
muchísimas personas pues ven en peligro
su modo de subsistencia a eso se sabe se
suma una falta de infraestructuras pues
en una gran medida debido a la
inestabilidad que ha causado las
distintas guerras de las últimas décadas
y finalizamos con uno de nuestros temas
del día el negocio el superbowl hablamos
el anuncio de amazon durante la pausa
durante la pausa de este mega partido el
megaevento en eeuu que es el domingo no
exacto y uno de los anuncios como
comentaba será el de amazon el de alexa
y está protagonizado por scarlett
johansson y colín josh viene el anuncio
ya se puede ver en internet y ha sido
criticado por muchas personas que
señalan que en este en este comercial
scarlett johansson y su pareja imaginan
un mundo en que alexa evoluciona y pasa
de predecir nuestro comportamiento y
nuestros deseos como ya lo hace a leer
completamente nuestras mentes pero sin
todo se desarrolla todo el guión de una
forma bastante graciosa y anecdótica y
pues muchos internautas han señalado que
realmente está este escenario sería
completamente distópico y parece que es
al que pues podemos dirigirnos ya veces
ha pasado rosa uno piensa cosas y de
repente la ve en las redes sociales la
ven nos e instagram facebook y dices wow
yo estaba pensando eso porque me aparece
aquí a lo mejor puede ser una casualidad
por ahora porque por supuesto no creo
que nos lean la mente pero bueno todo
puede pasar a lo mejor en un futuro
cierto es un tema muy complejo y muy
interesante que si te parece abordaremos
algún diario por favor te lo agradezco
rosa muchísimas gracias feliz fin de
semana